but I really love that character but I
think aren't they doing something now
with well they are fantastic well you
know what I mean in the Multiverse all
bets you can have six different Johnny
storms yeah I guess that's true I mean I
guess all bets are off um yeah look I I
would love it I would love it that would
actually be an easier sell to me than
coming back as cap you know what I mean
what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some really really
interesting and exciting news about
Chris Evans possibly making his return
to the MCU and what's interesting is
that he could return to the MCU but not
as Captain America of course that is on
the table but in a couple of recent
interviews one being today where he was
asked about himself returning as Captain
America he was also asked before about
returning as Johnny storm in which he
said he would love to and if the rumors
going around about Johnny Storm
returning in some particular movies are
true it does indeed look like we'll see
Chris Evans back in the MCU even if it's
not as Captain America however this
morning in an interview with Good
Morning America he did talk about maybe
returning us cap and kind of what that
would take for him and honestly it gives
us hope that he could return to the MCU
for both roles and just imagine what
that would be like on screen to actually
see just imagine a big portal scene like
we got in Avengers endgame happening in
Avengers Secret Wars big portals from
other universes open up and a bunch of
different variants come through them all
arriving on one world it could be a
battle world like in the comics and out
comes Johnny Storm from one portal and
then Captain America from another both
played by Chris Evans that is pretty
much exactly what we want from Avengers
Secret Wars old characters coming back
and meeting variants of themselves and
then fighting alongside our current
Heroes that we have in the main MCU well
based off of what Chris Evans has said
in some recent interviews one being this
morning this is entirely possible and
Chris Evans is actually down to do this
we'll break the whole thing down and if
you love Marvel be sure to subscribe to
stay up to date and also if you
subscribe and comment on our videos you
enter our giveaway for a chance to win a
lot of cool stuff including a PS5 Xbox
series X and more we'll pick a winner at
the end of each month so first let's
break down what Chris Evans said in his
interview with good morning America this
morning talking about possibly returning
as Captain America in the MCU then dive
into when he spoke about returning as
the Human Torch and then we'll dive into
where Johnny Storm or Captain America
could show up besides Secret Wars
because we obviously know that that's
possible so Chris Evans went on Good
Morning America this morning to talk
about his upcoming film that he stars in
ghosted and the first thing that he says
is that there are some Marvel cameos in
his upcoming movie trip like that Marvel
fans are going to be happy here some
cameos
there are some cameos that's right can
we give that away I guess I guess yeah
we had some we had some old Marvel
buddies back and uh you know I hate
asking people for cameos right so it's
the worst but some people like doing it
um you know if it fits into their
schedule I suppose but but these guys
they they roasted The Challenge and they
were there for me it was great so if
you're interested in his new movie
ghosted there are going to be some
cameos from some old Marvel actors
possibly even some current Marvel actors
maybe Mark Ruffalo maybe Chris Hemsworth
will have to wait and see on that but
the cool takeaway here is that he does
consistently keep in touch with his old
Marvel buddies and then he goes on to
talk about possibly returning as Captain
America are you gonna pick up the shield
again as Captain America oh man you know
as much as much as I would love to I
mean that was such a special time in my
life I'm very precious with the
character that's the problem I'm so
protective of it to come back it would
have to be for the right reasons and the
right timing it feels a little too soon
you know Anthony Mackey is Captain
America right now there's other stories
to tell
um for now we we ended on such a good
note I I would be too worried about
um tarnishing that so what's interesting
here is that Chris Evans let's say
concerns are basically what concerns
that Hugh Jackman had and Patrick
Stewart had Patrick Stewart said he
wouldn't return as Professor Xavier
because he wouldn't want to undo what
happened in Logan his death the ending
and Hugh Jackman said the same thing
that he said goodbye to his character
and Logan with that character's death
however look where we are now Patrick
Stewart returned in Multiverse of
Madness and Hugh Jackman has confirmed
himself as we all know that he is
returning as the Wolverine and why are
they returning because they are playing
kind of different variants of themselves
so the events that happened in Logan
won't be affected by these new
appearances in the MCU at all so
basically Marvel told them a about the
Multiverse what all it meant how
variants are different their stories are
different and Hugh Jackman and Patrick
Stewart said oh okay as long as it
doesn't undo what happened before I'm
game and that's pretty much exactly what
Chris Evans just said well what he said
that he would love to come back but two
he is very protective of the character
however he feels that it's too soon and
they ended on such a good note he would
be afraid of tarnishing the character
well that's exactly what the other two
were afraid of but the Multiverse makes
everything possible plus secret Wars is
years away down the road so hopefully
enough time would have passed for Chris
Evans to say okay this isn't going to
affect my Captain America Legacy and
enough time has passed I can make a
cameo as Captain America in secret Wars
but let's also talk about when he said
he would love to make a cameo as the
Human Torch he said this last year about
returning as the Human Torch in an
interview with MTV but here's my
question there were a lot of rumors that
like you could come back in the
Multiverse as another Marvel character
you played Johnny
no no one's ever come to me about that I
mean I don't exactly look the same
anymore I was 15 almost 20 years ago oh
my God
um but I really love that character but
I think aren't they doing something now
with well they are fantastic well I mean
in the Multiverse all bets you can have
six different Johnny storms yeah I guess
that's true I mean I guess all bets are
off um yeah look I I would love it I
would love it that would actually be an
easier sell to me than coming back as
cap you know what I mean cap is right so
precious to me and you know I I almost
don't want to disrupt what a beautiful
experience that was but Johnny Storm I
feel like he didn't really get his day
that was before Marvel really found its
footing so I I loved that role and you
know who knows so Chris Evans literally
said that it would be an easier sell for
him to come back as the Human Torch
rather than to come back as Captain
America and if you've been following the
channel and following all the news
recently you've heard the rumor that
Chris Evans in the entire original
Fantastic Four have a good chance at
returning in Deadpool 3. the rumor for
Deadpool 3 is that Deadpool and Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine are going to be
visiting other universes this is
basically going to be a giant Multiverse
road trip with Wolverine and Deadpool
and one of the universes that they're
going to go into is the old Fantastic
Four Fox Universe now it's also rumored
that they're going to see the original
X-Men as well so this could be the same
universe that the X-Men are in or it
could simply be two separate universes
they go to one they see the Fantastic
fourth they go to a different one they
see the X-Men but this could be where it
all happens in Deadpool 3. this is where
Chris Evans could officially return as
the Human Torch and finally have that
character in the MCU it's what a lot of
the original actors for the Marvel
movies really wanted now Chris Evans is
different because obviously he played
Captain America in the MCU so he's been
in the MCU however the rest of the
Fantastic Four haven't the same thing
goes with the old X-Men characters they
have not been in the MCU so the actors
want to return just so they can finally
take part in it which was one thing that
Hugh Jackman said before he made us
return as Wolverine that he wish he
could have made it into the MCU and I'm
sure a lot of those original X-Men
actors feel the same way which is why we
are probably getting them back we've had
many reports state that they are coming
back in Deadpool 3 and then again in
secret Wars but keep in mind we have
heard that the movies and the shows that
happen after Kang Dynasty they are all
going to take place in the Multiverse so
whatever movies and shows that we get in
between Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars
those could be movies and shows that
take place in other universes they show
the other universes fighting Kang and
then in secret Wars all of the universes
come together and this is honestly a
great idea because one you don't have to
cram everything into Secret Wars and two
it makes us a lot more emotionally
invested in these other universes and
the characters that are in these
universes that way when they appear on
screen we're actually invested in them
and we care if they die or not so I
think it's actually kind of likely that
Chris Evans does return as the Human
Torch in Deadpool 3. simply based on
what they're trying to do with the story
of Deadpool 3 and then of course there's
the possibility that he could appear
anywhere in between the King Dynasty and
then of course in secret Wars and I
think as far as him returning as Captain
America goes he definitely wants to
return he's open to returning as long as
enough time passes by and the story is
okay which makes Secret Wars perfect
because he can play a different variant
of himself he's not coming back as the
same Captain America but a new one from
a different universe and perhaps he
could even have a different attitude
which I think would also be exciting for
him as an actor but the main thing is
Chris Evans is open to returning as both
the Human Torch and Captain America and
I hope we get that scene in secret Wars
when they both appear and they both
interact with each other maybe even have
a funny scene where Captain America goes
why did you get superpowers and I ended
up as Captain America what Went
different why do we look exactly the
same I can't wait for this I hope
something like this happens and I hope
he returns as both characters but let us
know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video video And subscribe and leave
a comment so you can enter our giveaway
you can also follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof foreign